first let me give you a disclaimer I
don't personally teach a course in
leadership but I think I know a bit
about the business of leadership what
defines good leadership I think it to be
very you know at the very essence of it
is a sense of character and values I
think a good leader has values that are
clear and clear to the organization and
also has a sense of what the goals of
the organization are and is able to
communicate them and stay focused on
them and I think if you have a strong
sense of values and are good at
communicating that message in
communicating the objectives then then
people will follow you and ultimately
that's what what leadership is about
it's about getting people to to go along
with you
you